the United States is clearly pushed back
against the quote unquote Siege of Gaza
the cutting off of water and fuel
electricity and so forth and clearly the
United States is counseling restraint
and if I had to summarize the American
policy it's go after Hamas but don't go
after Gaza so rather than going big
going small whether it's from the air or
from the ground and my guess is that
will be closer to what ultimately
happens that I think there's a lot of
Israeli who also have fundamental doubts
about the wisdom of going ahead with a
large ground operation all the costs all
the international outcry the possibility
it would lead to war widening and then
at the end of it it's not clear again
how you establish political Authority in
Gaza Israel saw that in 2005 and it's
not at all obvious to most observers
that if they went in big now and then
left they would have a lot to show for
it